[Music]
what do we have I'm sorry
white male 20s dropping the n-word in
front of his co-workers Thomson it is
our duty to stop these races mishaps
before they take place
bring him in is happy y'all that it
shock let's it go
yeah cap you wanted to see me so what
the hell took you so long
that wasn't fast I'm sorry told myself
that was stop yelling so much
Joseph meet your new partner detective
Albert
she's very impressive top marks at the
Academy first in her class and cultural
sensitivity you know I don't need a
partner I do my best work alone yes yes
yes yes well that is not an option Joel
I need you to have backup let's not
forget about the Reb appropriation that
was October 29th 1989 the darkest Diwali
too many sorry's not enough sorry's all
right rook let's see how long you last
this is the Red Room where we receive
all of our assignments and this must be
the Oracle who can see people do racist
things before they actually do them so
lucky guess we formed a minority bureau
based off of the Oracles premonitions we
bring those culprits in front of Lady
Justice
so we arrest them sort of we more so
just give them like it for talking to
hosannah five minute thirty nice new
record
yep hey Johnson all right
Caucasian male at D door paper ink ten
miles east from here cool we'll grab a
late lunch then we'll head there
wait what time did this crime occur 130
[ __ ] we got to move Brooke Bingbing
take a left up here nope all right oh my
god damn it Brooke this is the library
that's it throw a shot
hey stop with a keyhole paint right
where they can't go King Taco just
because I know thanks they can't know
what time is it I don't know
you
[Music]
I'm just like what the hell are you
doing sir I'm I need you to slowly step
away from your coworkers what's going on
sir what you're about to say is not
permitted by your race oh come on
but these mom please don't do this
you're hurting more than you're helping
but what if I or if I am what if there's
a rap song and I'm rapping along I swear
to God i'ma beat show ass okay um
I am so incredibly sorry I just I think
I really admire you guys and I think
you're super cool and deep down I wanted
to feel cool too and that was wrong
amen you know what's cool my personality
no not getting swung on Oh
plus we know you'll get fired if you do
say it so wait what thank you
am I really getting fired hey what's up
man
I was a good one too back there don't
get cocky usually that last one doesn't
get through to people into a few hours
of arguing and to plays up to pimp a
butterfly so it doesn't get easier from
here it doesn't but you get better come
on partner
I got a super one zero at the Cheesecake
Factory Oh oh no car we've got a young
woman we're not Native American and a
Drizella rain check
rain check
[Music]
[Music]
lonely
[Music]
ah